[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
paris est ici nous sommes à 15 km de la
capitale sur l'opération d'intérêt
national paris saclay qui s'étend sur
sept mille 700 hectares le coeur a été
sanctuarisée par une zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière qui
s'étend sur plus de 2300 hectares et les
franges sont en cours d'aménagement et
se développe sur des quartiers existants
qui accueille 10 % de la recherche
française nous devons simultanément
réfléchir à des échelles distinctes à
celle du le territoire de
l'établissement public donc cher environ
30 kilomètres simultanément aussi à
l'échelle du sud du plateau où sont
regroupés l'essentiel des campus
aujourd'hui donc sur environ 7 km puis
enfin nous devons aussi imaginer la mise
en oeuvre d' espaces publics pour l'un
des quartiers pour environ 3 km c'est
une échelle inédite de projet nous a
semblé dès le début un très important de
nous faire accompagner par une équipe de
maîtrise d'oeuvre urbaine et paysagère
là où d'habitude on ne fait que de la
planification réglementaire parce que
pour nous la question du paysage était
la clé d'entrée du projet nous nous
sommes tous référé un exemple
relativement récent tout début du 20e
siècle
l'expansion du campus georgetown près de
washington s'est faite justement avec un
paysagiste comme leader de
de cette équipe de mise en oeuvre bien
sûr il y avait beaucoup de prêts
existence à saclay notamment et campus
importants souvent de l'ordre de 200
hectares comme le cera au fond ce qui
apparaît très fort dans ce territoire
sur les cartes bien sûr mais aussi dans
le site ce sont ces coteaux boisés ses
coteaux boisés constituent des lignes
d'horizon depuis le plateau comme depuis
les vallées l'amplification de ses
présences boisé c'est l'élément physique
qui peut donner la cohérence à un
ensemble préexistant de lieux de
recherche qui sont dispersés la
géographie amplifiée est un élément de
cohérence qui opère aussi pour ce
cadrage de 7 km c'est la ligne d'horizon
c'est là doucement mais il est
nécessaire également pour ses sept
kilomètres d'avoir un système de parcs
ce que nous appelons d'air une visière
qui va donner la cohérence à tous les
quartiers cette maquette permet
d'apprécier ce que sera la lisière à
terme donc la lisière c'est l'espace de
transition paysagère entre les terrains
écoles d'une part et les différents
quartiers du campus urbain
nous avons réussi à dégager environ 200
hectares sur sept kilomètres de long
avec l'ambition d'installer une chaîne
de park une chaîne d' espaces publics
qui relie tous les usages de ces campus
bien sûr et surtout avec l'ambition de
créer un paysage intermédiaires qui
assurent de meilleures transition entre
le bâti et la campagne
nous disposons de nombreux leviers il
s'agit de gérer les eaux de cet immense
quartier
il s'agit de localiser des mesures
compensatoires au fond d'eux l'idée
toute simple c'est de fabriquer un
paysage avec ses leviers de faire de ces
contraintes à l'élément de financement
de gestion de construction du paysage
dont nous avons besoin pour établir un
meilleur rapport entre les quartiers et
la campagne donc la lisière agricole
s'organise
naturellement avec le parcellaire
existants et c'est dans ces traces que
nous installons les fossés les nous les
bassins certaines dépressions qui
permettent en effet d'une part de
stocker l'eau mais également d'installer
toute une série de zones humides
il fait de s'inscrire dans un paysage
extraordinaire c'est la volonté à un peu
innovante de méthodologique de pouvoir
intégrer cette dimension de lien entre
la ville et son environnement entre la
ville et le paysage avoisinants qui très
riche
nous travaillons maintenant depuis près
de dix ans avec michel desvigne ce temps
long du projet nous a permis de mûrir
une solution qui nous semble apporter
une réponse à une problématique
essentielle aujourd'hui qui est la
transition entre les villes et
l'agriculture
[Musique]
oh
nous